So this is Laura here Ellie and I here at the diaper branch of the public library
Today is January twenty ninth and they're here with Nelson and so
we're going to hear your
story a story about a
year. To a could become picture.
And I just want to raise my own too much of my niece an apartment over
here house and she invited me to go to movie as I noted I go and I says.
To Betty had reaction as. I always I always remote about one sixty and
says I would like one ninety nine trying to fight my rector When Shifty yet I
know
everyone has a crystal.
And when days since I've been over here. I'm a big guy he goes to church every day.
I told when I got up you know please but I wasn't smart
enough and I was good enough so I never really was able to come. But
I pray did go to prayer groups and I was a pretty good leader. I went
to jail and spoke with inmates I stepped in a gym
in the gym at night and supervised the homeless.
Out of my way just to stay overnight with them and pushes in the
church used to make to make a meal. Nice to feed the
homeless stay overnight with him. And I mean should
do you really did and what I read in court for you but Chris and then the then
the homeless bus used to take him back. I just kept in a shut overnight to
keep medical.
And then and I went directly to
work with it before you did
I already have before it isn't just before I went to
Samos for the law to say much but.
Whenever it in any way that when it is yes I could
do it like. From eighty seven
to two thousand
and twelve or thirteen. My biggest fear is and I can one
day I was go to church every day began to be rigid in
and doing God's work why not let not a volunteer not a volunteer in a church.
I don't get paid as you go and I was and what the Course SEXTON The second is a guy who was just
a message to wade and you
know if you do all those and on Sunday or you go on Sunday and just
sort of the regular masses and a funny thing happened we had to change to
Sunday to Sunday I went to no side it went. How much snow detail just no details I want
to shovel snow shoveling all day and to church and also my wife called me
Joe do you know there's no transportation home. As a man. So I went for
lunch and in the place or use eat
lunch. They told me I couldn't stay. Because their whole
Isn't that a good to call home. And so so I will back and I I
I didn't go to church and then I asked my son is in charge of the church so
anyway I had to stay overnight. I stayed overnight at the church and if you.
I felt a few a few times that my son's welcome. And I said oh
and tomorrow I can go home but I was going to schedule said to sex and for Sunday
you join us
and so I had to stay all day and Holly nobody comes so that day I was
assured
that I did every day and a time I went home with the four five
hostages two days I went home and my lashes don't while I'm a good idea to be
home so I went to W. and Ocean Park where to get a bus and we knew about an hour and I
have had when I left the bus was still wanted. As I didn't want to walk home
and shit to read.
No she said where are you. I said I'm on air you double sure Joe us have a senior
moment the bus stops at every
X. so that I have off to every action I got to bus. And I went home no I got
home I dig out my
car and do a lot of things what I had to do in the house and Ciccio time I went to bed
for four o'clock and one
in that day and I'm still recuperating
from Watertown but anyway. She had to work again Sunday to live
on C.N.N.
Sunday but I know they had me and I go one day I went to church and I came up I came
out of the church who was the lady's name is Dr
and I came in today. I came in to. I try to come into the library but it was
cause I pass by it was a big big thing like that.
And I looked in the
bag and helping up. It was all of twenty's and hundreds and
knowledgeably in the library and library steps. It was all
twenty's hundred credit cards in it so I said now what I do it is not my own shop made and I was
very big tonight when I go my
errands try printing I went and went to my
bank. And I called my wife and I said look I found as big as it was one.
So I went to my Jamaica owns one home.
I open to dating. I saw the number and then the lady just she just
made electro Gees one hundred dollars you are Jordan Chase it was a hundred she has
a credit card so I stand just that and then I call the lady and her name is Rosemary
does for you. She's a man and Joe Jaish was it was
weird. I found I found a lady's wallet with all of the
ID money in it I says I want to she said Joe could you do your back I said
I showed I just want. I should I want four miles every
day and I fast. Once a week a couple meals for the poor kids in the world and
one day a week but twenty years on me. I Wednesday and when I don't eat on Wednesday.
I say do you guys just eat only I said I eat mice.
And I could feel a tribe I guess any so I pray to God as a good a miracle man.
I hope I hope you
could direct is food I skip to the porkies. And I get a
good charity I go to charity every day. And I can assure you you day.
I pray for disarmament. You know it's always us I don't turn to as a kind of I am but I'm
just saying that's with maybe the priest I wanted to be but we did I wanted to go.
Didn't get a chance to I tell you went to
jail just to sit and talk with inmates and say Look change it all I you
know I don't put too much religion on I said change your life reach out to God and I said I
don't I did and and then I and I was a pretty good leader and a basically free
to bio precinct you know just
songs not tourist but no homeless to give to charity to help all people who
don't and I should but I didn't know a lady would talk about the who was debacle.
So please if I come back I said as you. You know I said I want for most everything I want for miles
every day.
And I don't exercise every day I'm going to exercise and one and I says.
And a lady
I just looked at the lady was a possible good enough. I thought about what I have the money
and here I should tell the lady to come to my house I said I can one back I
just tell you so so Lady fine came to my house my wife we are sorry lady came to
my house and the lady would come I was seen as
I was a torrential downpour. My wife got soaked Clady got
soaked but she got to the house. I told her she says
you know what to do is what you do and I said to him. She said just very nice to you
and we will for the launch we offer
the no to what happened. She said what happened I was going to the stores I bought.
I bought a big hit it very day and I got to the library to go arrest all
the big down there and then I put all the babies up but I forgot that
one and I said take your money for forty hours a day with us not just an inch or
so we took it and
then another sad story when I was a lot of good deeds and I
didn't when I first was one time a Holmes guy.
I was trying to help out all the time and one time I had I got extra money actually I
said Bob He was a veteran here and he said to dispute his wife new to strictly street.
She wonders why Bob let me treat workers today. So I vomited I know I go you eat.
He said at one table I said it was. Lazy. I
created but then he walked out and then only Comeau Can you see Joe was
a nice Dean you did but don't do it again I said way he should be my question was could use most
of it.
So sometimes you try to do good and another time. That was in my
car I said Yes in ninety seven and another time I was I was at the Port
Authority I was at support of the free and already been ninety years old she was
trying to put on the underwear
again and I said Do you know God will help and in a black eye pondering
about it how long have I been praying on always.
A meal I was just an attorney and I was assistant one machine
company. I had three hundred dollars in my pocket and I was going out to dinner but I saw the old lady I
try to help her and how long have I been prairie and all ladies. You
know and even you know that you know the do or don't do undercover cops and the lady was
a lady was like that like a dick way and they you know they do
and and I was and I was a guy
that's known they were going to back and I had a nice knife my dad gave me to go show you had this negative.
Station narrative me to back it up put it all in about it and it gave a detainee about three hours and I call my wife my
wife verify me now let me go but they want me up a little bit
too ignorant to the nice bank my dad gave me a job. So all these things I did
I didn't directly or the system for ME machine or company when daily driver and I lost
sight and two cops because. I have big black down to be like I was just
as young Spanish did about me to be able hundred twenty pounds to get out of here. It
was time enough and I jumped at the high level and I said I had no police no and
they did i only to bring the stage. Obstructing justice. I'm a moat you
know you try to do good or you know it or something I see it. I gotta
walk and he's trying to get to rush island
off. He talks about ME ALONE I do it myself to try to do good and
sometimes a gender but but I drive like I drive
a cab and I. Should I go get a book but I slowly but surely statue.
I drove the Caribbean. You know and then you know I was a good hold up a few
times a guy talk about I pick just who
I separated my first
wife. I went to the child support and I said to them I went knock on doors and so
what do you do we help you I said I'm here to volunteer child support shit.
Oh I can't believe you show we have to catch them all and you're coming here to volunteer so
I
volunteered and then she said and then you know I volunteer child support and I says.
And I says that as George I directing is an idiot. You know you get jammed up
Newton and generation is a good and I don't know how to drive a cab because
I know what it would have a chance of a church at a time. I mean for jobs a week at
a time. I had to pay up and I had paid my role and then the time. I prayed every day
I don't have much money. My house so I don't have to drive
to compensate and myself you
know but a lot of the good things and and not taught my boys to be altar boys
I took in the to be all good things in life and now one of my sons adjusted to church
years I was a sensation worker mother so I work for a school
system. I was always an I was and seven a parent I was only as a teaching and one
day I was always on the phone directing new trying to show in the way you know meeting the older
boys in the church to always do a career and not a not a breeder OK One of my sons is in charge
or to church is he doing God's work. You know
me go out. You know a lot of money and I know I have another son I so I know
Son His wife's a nurse and she works three days a week she made one hundred fifteen thousand dollars a
year
and I mean as she said when you. When do you tell me I'm not very domestic. I'm not
very domestic but I make a lot of money and my son makes a lot of
money and one day she said Dad I bought my wife a watershed.
I bought Oh it's twelve thousand dollars. I said to him but you never bought me a time each.
You buy a lot of
action and if you know it's you know she said and last year I bought a model Votto sure I'd watch and
try to put on the shelf mouse and then she says and she shakes hundred dollar pillows and I
should drive a Lexus I guess or you work three days a week
and you're gone you're forgiven doesn't. And you had a majority don't you do us of it I know. But
then it
was just the story right in the cab.
You know and. This is a good story driving a cab I know it's a good story as
a one time driving a cab and I was as I was I was a note today when you're I
was driving again and a nose and
this black guy said to me sent a white boy. What would you do if I tried to argue.
I said well black boy what you certain is a dead man
seat you generalize me. I may get hurt but I guarantee
you when I slam the back of the hall and toward you go die tonight and show every kid in the movie
you know gee you change a story day you know and then I tell you I volunteered to go some I know I
volunteered
to go to Somalia to help the people and I got to NY dead. I didn't try to do to no avail.
Then I joined I tried to join the national gut and I says I tried I tried
to join Vietnam but I got a little alone with the law and I was able go to
Vietnam and I try to join at this time I joined it thirty seven when I went
back to interview. He says sorry Mr Nelson you get thirty you're too old.
So I do you know I did I didn't I didn't make it on our show to help people
like I said I was just only going to church. I tell you the sake. Can you help me out
I never died and I anybody to actually you know Street money a dollar or
two so I guess me he said I said I only have twenty cents.
Change or twenty you tell me I show yesterday for the holiday when I was working in a church and out
of the other windows were going to church
it and then one told me Joe. Mrs Sullivan come up a turkey.
And she requested a sheet for she needs a
family get a turkey in Jewish Boston. So I walked a draw to get the latest
the traces. Ahead. So I can to you and I why not I just got
my nails done. And then I said man she took over Turkey in which
poor that you and Ellen and I know and it gave me a beauty
Polish bring it out to the car. I've had a hard to because I got that I'm sure what you are.
She's coming here for support and use it as you are not boy you know
I saw it then and then I just.
And how many do you maybe haven't changed I like to like when I meet you
Jeanette and a nice guy should now a nice wide shot and two
kids radio's African union guy takes a
pocket change of vox but he got away on a lot of things
that you have what was in the church and that's a mark
to the ladies that D.N. the lady
said in Joe is like a fourth priest at the church and I'm not I'm
you Christian minister I should go division to people you know all the old people.
And so. I'm not a police but I'm a minister or not he was
minister and what I was I'm a commune you know I pray would make what I would hospital.
I went to jail. So I went I went I went I went to get a sense of Christian
times from different countries and not to me you would always and
then I go to hold because I want to give last rites. When I fell
but I was quite myself I've been to a neighborhood that a black preacher
Matthew and he went he was a battalion and I was tested what he preaches here to bless you
mom who
died for you black boys do you told me he said I don't want no food
and black food. And if we should
require What are you to Bridge doing. Stories like that
and you said you know what books I
don't like Washington burgers like
this like. It's like well you know Washington Bono as a possible.
I mean on I mean.
What was it like growing up because I said.
I said I'm my mother five fourteen
kids and I was separated and separated and I my father my
father was like the one that my mother's like fifty six I was thirty six. So I
always feel bad I reference as they were going to make game tonight what is it. Do you
think your grandfather would like to know what was in my mouth with my father you know and and I thought it
was never you know great basketball me you know my kids I couldn't have written my father
was it you know never I mean do you know in one place my father my whole life that was to blow out and it
was you know the load goes and he bombed a lot of bestiality I went to my father
son and I my mother. My mom my mother like
she was a kind of always been you know I was always I sometimes I was seven years old my
mother my mother want to go out
and she say Joseph She did your friend over to my we not play games you
did your friend over to I get a kick I get the care and I go to my friends.
And he Campos
away cause my mother to go out and. Now the seven years old defend myself so
I left and myself and I said. The only let me. I
know I've been working since seven years old I said I was watching T.V. I saw
a cliche she could record it on
T.V. So when my mother. Of course I do put claim
a shoot
a side I made seven dollars some point shiny
shoes newspapers at thirteen I had no not on
stand at fifty No it would be a milkman as soon as Labor and when
you have me I mean it's just implement what you do with the money that I mean I put in a bank I would
have thought I'd got married. But again being young and.
I got married couple times and I was married once and I don't aggressively green you know.
I messed up and out
of town and a big mistake and I. But.
To do I believe is that you know
that I made every effort to return it to a mistake I made every effort to return and make
amends to my weight and
wanted people to do I feel bad about I said
no because I repeat. Because I believe in like reconciliation to go to
the fishing and I confess that oh god so sorry I made a mistake. I did I
made every effort to be true knows of some stake on my part and that it's time I've
gotten by with drugs and sorted into houses.
I mean I met a girl she worked for. She worked on
youngish Kowloon
again. She's a secretary for calling again and when I when I. When I met
her she told me why I want to be like a group in
the fifty's or soon was black
so I went back. And I never I don't even I
was afraid it was my call to do try to go but I went back and they had to beat me like a sugar
bowl or cocaine. And I tried it and and
I want Richman to and and and and then and as time at the time I found God.
And I maybe.
I messed up. I want some top man to go man just a form of How To cause to wear.
But again I guess. I did I did but again not to
go through books off my
show but I was kind of guy who will G. diamond rings or one
hundred thousand dollars in my pocket and I go oh my gosh I'm going boss and I go try
to call or talk to me so I don't talk to me sure why not this you know I have an appointment. You know this kind of
guy was I always would I mean French calls
and I would have passed because I was knowledge in my pocket and I
wanna do what I want no I did but then
I bought it and I'm glad I blow
it we don't know if it didn't happen to me
I was still doing all the same things really a deal is making money you can do
just like but I'm happy every day.
And when I found a very dirty seven having done it I was
your family
religion biodata I've gone out on a mountain and I said he even like I said
that I got my life and that my life I want to go back and request. I went
to the girls but I said and then it
hit and then she had two sisters it. Don't give me a chance to do it again. But
I don't know I was fifteen years celibate. I didn't go away and and everybody
when I went to God may move one you'll go dance for me and I tell the go
to dance you because you
might. I don't know if you don't know how to dance like a lady she skipped an exams or
some girl I have a hard time I carry a
bible to go out and it's I want to show you night
bible five hundred times when you push me a lot to me I'm going to said that in the Bible.
I'm going to love to you. And you have to cut off in the church in the church on time.
But again mention that and your church home
and I'm sure you want to do I so much to the game to getting to get into a zone to play a
series and then to have wine and cheese and it was going
alone and in fact.
I go I should but Nick and I had all I
like and I'm the guy you turned on night or should I go tonight a night of early.
Years and because you're trying to do
that for no no no just just just because I think guessing that you guys doing on it was
a relationship for your marriage. I would have relationships I was married I married
again
now I know I've been issued under Scripture and in my life in the church. No I've looked into church
or church secretary as usual to teach about living good church I work
for a religion to kids in school and then she called
me for drugs. I mean I was always going to
church or judge will push you know to a put air condition.
According to Josh. But air conditioning on the move clinic voters and so I did show snow
from everything I did wish I were going to church and then also there's a job
and and. I had to work seventy hours a day so tight sometimes driving
can work up many times. Scruton situs wrestling
on a Sunday and I separate B.C. I'm going to vote their jersey and I have to win the why don't
the snow in A.Z. sure snow in the car when you hosed the wind and
I have a guest like Miss I don't know guessed it vacant the window to stay awake
but you know at the center you know you push a horse too much.
So that said you know I was driving but I just did without a do
it trying to survive guy got me through a new I did
you did you get it right is that you already know how I learned to drive.
I picked you up as you were lose your downtown book and I said How do you go down
here and show us how I don't know the byways Well try your bill I don't know any
way that when I first started I know basic in your book and I get to not
hear what people tell me neighbors in several years ago I don't want to go to
Kennedy Why do you usually go sure. I'm sure you are no acquittal
I don't try your way tonight you know what I mean I don't even know you do what I had to do
you know that I knew that I was trying to be fair and honest
and as you do a lot of Joshua pre-political me I say tickle me that shapes joke. I
want to go to Pennsylvania. Do you have. As you
know he has you do all the moving man movement
Kansas eight hundred eight hundred nine hundred pasta truck. So I always was
fair to the people my son said
it was to feel it was sometimes a people to get ready one day a lady called
me. I said if your for be for nothing if you if you have
no money. I try to find out now if you fifteen to people have money.
I will literally a seven figure age which put on a vision I said but you better call a moving man
file
nomos So if you do a show in the car. Floods the basement also something which I think event.
Try to help the people. He actually shows. He
would three dollars I shows
are as good as you can shovel and will buy me a coffee occasionally
I always try to be fair with the people and I tell you every
day every day my re not ised version us into a charity every day for
the Jewish part is to have the edge through discernment and I said which
I would go to church to candle. I don't need to support us anyway I
see an issue. I don't go I see a homeless guy don't use
your eyes you can just say. And if you don't know like twenty or thirty.
As they could do something. But but they actually need. You but I just don't go and get to
the
cup but if people actually. Or something I've been on many lines like I see
an old lady and as a
Miss you don't have enough money. I said yes she does but I want to have a meal. I
said yes she does I had the difference in astronomy
as I told
it as a kind of guy but.
Oh sure I do I do hope the underdog and.
Judge me address guys who do you write letters to my wife has
a job. And how to get what I was tested
I did some and and when I was a job something happens
you have to
me Your give us sixty seventy dozen dollars and what I have left
you. And me when you sit down have to begin.
To say my debt to my boys see my dads in a better
place with is no more pain does no more Salo does no Marge good.
He's happy. So he don't want to be said he enjoyed
my wiped away no black usually laugh about my dad she meant my dad
always kids yet it is number one rule is what your mother made needle for Measure
did he always say. What you want but remember
you will eat every day you take some time I could use a vision.
That was a fish supper five my mother's where I could read it all. And I was a
lazy ation so he knew he didn't need reading carriages retainers and my mother
going home which always finished and then after it was tried to from oh my mother's mother
stopped pushing you know but I never let my kids lose
and I said and what I when I die you know me I'll turn over in my grave.
So any you eat at each East each day. Whatever you do I'd eat but make sure you
don't look to take it out with to a dog or to another. But don't leave it.
And I don't I don't need all my eyes in my eyes and all
this is a. I just good thing we were sixty five years so I hope
it helps somebody else and I don't need all my obvious to two
people to songs which I do like doing that I'm going to question.
And I tell you I've passed a budget where. I don't tell us to act rationally.
But I just. But the intention my sense is that's a stupid thing to do
it didn't get that boot. I said but jeez is five
thousand people but if you're fishing if you read a story in the Bible.
So I'm sure he's a miracle that I'm sure when I see it when I put in as I pray when
I don't just do it to to do it as I do is a shape over to my plate my
my attention is I hope that the pool day will find some pork in the
world
maybe you could see that isn't as my my God on issues
of
where it's at in my head just like a priest only one time as a father and when I
sell drugs the old has a liquor store. Joe to worry about that shit
when you get the two dollars you know leave you can't you can tell the cops
who and who also
know you gave it a good intention. Every descent with a bad intention. Your Hands
know about it so I always do when I go I know what to do it till my drug judge knows I
gave I gave it a good eleven intention of going to church
new videos I went to when I
was when I was up to no good and one time I saw the city actually like fuck Well
an apostle who fired up the fire didn't one day go and a guy every day passed
by and he should not sending someone. This is minute a key he had
to play some I put money no time. And I see a big
little boy up. And I shoot a guy full name but some lesson Epicurean.
And getting a little.
Used to Sumit and you have watched people. Try to
give people mouth to mouth and meanwhile put in a pocket.
Do they die on the floor.
And it down that lead to helping me like that man is my partner trying to you
was you and I says I
know that I got an approval of a few of us are never any Sure.
When you voted to get off the good. You know I suppose
what have you all day tell you that anyway. It's only been broken by living
here about living in Brooklyn.
And
live in Brooklyn this is my best I was I guess is again given to Churchill
always doing good things in a.
Live in important mission. Its really
good spirited looking and I don't know if I had been in book and I think I have
been to hell and back. You know I says and I tell you my my my family
and I ten is seven years old and eight years old you want to defend yourself and
in this time when he comes forward and you
know this is a guest and did it I went to counseling and I was a wise
move for you great and denounce you maybe I do not have a.
But I didn't once did of what they do is write me very good discipline at home so they
can chill and then she's You see this is just an acknowledgment I press
down with my underwear she would have. If you hang out
hope to talk. But I was afraid to tell my
mother because my mother was a you disobey anon.
So I never told her so every day from for years as you know we do you have beaten which is actually going to
definitely get like that just like I am but it doesn't but if I was trying to give you the
discipline I have to give a shit idea she was going to discipline and I didn't get
home again and the last thing about governesses I love my work for the
church many years I
was I always was devoted all and I got you know the Catholic
celebrity kena time and I'll do that I'm here to give hundred ten
percent to
God church and I said I did a year and at one point when Tennyson a
priest a young priest to do. Cavender of a church even me I give
two dozen for the innovation he raised me in to do it but but then he always to me should
mistreat meat on the holidays I decorated for
Christmas and his volunteers and and us and a trough I said OK.
I said that preaches a lunch and then me I was God in it and him said See you
later Joe. And you get on Jeanette and then he
was there and the Opus was it goes makes you had a huge makes you had a meal
every
day and then he said Joe works hard as he could to produce one porch up
to you Should a priest don't do any I go to Joe do I maintain it and then when
Tommy came he said to me Joe there'd be no one wants for you. I don't wish
to assist. If you meet a church or do American for but now environment is very
nearly seven large.
So you should you know he wasn't fond of me he didn't like me and yet and then I was ten or parted on a few
no books
and eventually goes isn't as you go to the Julio's it loses. One of
A and then when he came when he was a big big PI who retired
recently and there's somebody come in to volunteer to say you know if you had to follow and said Joe don't
you count on you. So way everyone who time apart you how can you go at
your
question depresses invite me. And I guess I should have all
day and then sometimes kids come in for heart just answer the phone we were three hours I was all
day and he made me a new woman. How did I park my car they have like twenty years out of
my spot.
He was upon and
we have a spot you know Toyota Hilux just. Make you question.
But me and one has died when I went to jolt voters who go to
the post I was going to comment on as I said Man one thing about this
me not dollars view it I can't replace it once you call
girl. And in a time we are not me what he was. When he was dismissed and and after he let me
go get a look at the twenty seven years. I'm going to vote a different direction I
want
to hire cool a new crew you Heidi couldn't do the job they hired me.
To help them and then he said no he stopped though he said I couldn't she would check into company.
He
said huge and I'm going to I was looking at forty odd years ago. And she said I was a regular because
I was a re on my own initiative that I was making about how to make good
money and I was a about one hundred dollars so I told the police and who don't pay me I'm not
I want to get money from the jury.
I just bring a salary so he put me on six hundred dollars a week if I was a one hundred dollars one hundred
dollars had a six hundred I
know that I don't want to judge him by all of us and our allies got more money they took in a caution and this is
a no no no judgment. The judge or we're going to know about it I've noticed the same
ox and the gentleman valid you know get paid edge of and you and I
should have a just one and Sally until he let me go he said I should I sue could use you as a
guy I said to the
ranchers and anybody gonna give you fifteen dollars an hour and it took all my medical way I see about a month
because you do every case you know
I. I don't know how to live in my life where they're going to want to marry.
I married thirty seven I should walk we should fall down and she was
a vision. She got one percent vision edge developments and she a many things wrong with it I
just thought that I need to
medical. You and you know medical and he put me up with you know.
And then and any only a lot of back money to be a lot of back money.
I ten dollars in the early but ten thousand want to let me go as a father with a ten dollars you owe him
back. So I can afford to pay get it so I went down to the bishop
down nebbish Dimaggio So I went down it was I met with a high upset and he said to
me and you say you have a new record price had a verbal
agreement you know I know record. So I said no I'm not God Good turned out I mean I don't need
the money I have money I make money and I did take the ten thousand and
I don't need to die he
says you need to need it more to me and it was it was a new a
new ventilator. I get a get two thousand to a site. So I donated ten
dollars and back pretty old me I have a shower and snow come into my day joy
of holidays the only can dollar. So I said I don't need it today it's just
I give it to you I don't need I don't need it I said I retired who tired to my sons.
I said I don't believe in such a huge system I do. As I was fifty years I said I would hire
you and I would get two dozen pension and two dollars so she could saw get bored doesn't
want who had a day to me every day you wake up make two hundred I work just I
don't know but I just out of bed in my life but I just I just try
to God money not energy and I'm coming after I've paid
my Premier's is what I was
going to how to how to fish but if I could have a kind
of progress. That was called a social I believe that's what I'm just happy to do
you know.
And I mean you know I'm a big guy may not live on but I don't I don't want to mother my ex-wife and she
said to me Joe you can. Take us no idea of the table before we did a
full retreat addresses straight to drink coffee.
So it was a time. You
know so. Again. Again I
was when I put when I play. And I
got there only I tried my eyes and I may have not done my best today.
But you know I have tried my best you know how my hundred and my best
I have tried my best. I try to be good to my wire
and my wife I
says my wife I met them and I said I met my wife and I said in the rectory
Yes And what do you do for a living shithole I'm a religion teacher. I'm
a nurse and I don't have. And I said I went to church but it will
be my birthday.
Because I turned down many girls I beg to know many girls are trying to involve me I don't
know me and I had not identified and I made my way I met my wife and I
know I found out I was more religious than
her. And then she should listen to pray and to meet
and joke when when my going to buy you the hotline.
And I said I was not she said I'm fanatical to lead
you to
my English Church you mean. Jordan one dirty mass I go to twelve.
Because I want to show him the statue
or times well as a sheet of paper you go to church
every
day. I can I can
those Noni wanted to candles dome and donate
money and now I
have you know and I says I'm not to go back and do that
now but it's and that's what I do every day. And I love my true and I hope I do you
know and I just and I pray God. Today I don't want I
will no longer I will I just when you will you want to me recently
just a minute you are sure whether you want me to meet
my bad break. But I prayed
to God I prayed as I move
to God through His people. My
family and to do that and I begin
to exercise and things happen in the good moments and I get up and do I'm
sorry pushups on your
majority and of course a day I usually do about two hundred years and I went for months.
Under the Sun But yesterday I was running my foot
and the gym the gym my gma gym is on.
Like fifteen hours have a car have a bike connecting a
bus that used to walk your to be able to we had as your ideal one day not
walked over and in the snow and. But I choose to do that.
I pay one twenty five in a bus but under no bus. I was
no by choice and I was you crazy is no way. I
said that my workout. So I won.
And then no one picked I want to do your back and reggae did
you know how I did bike weights just a joke.
Do you know one of my creators told me joke as I said my only just as
I always been one sixty. I said they would have a lot of a truly big.
I would win ninety I said trying to get back to. I said I don't want
to go back on a diet I got to the god like me to be the mirror you know.
A lesson I learned our lesson I want to acknowledge in my
dove full weeks I was one thirty five and my doctor told
me you want me back and one would want fifty one sixty S. My good weight
back to front of about one
hundred. When
you need no lunch.
Just one meal and I want my meal and I for you.
So again. I think I
could do it well not passed away. I want to talk
to my Web a month. Got it
but. I figure I always
forgive I guess.
I sometimes doesn't like tradition but if you stage.
You know I said one time I says I met my wife and I said to my wife and I met her she
said Joe I bought a twenty dollars so I said here. Here's my A.T.M.
card go to demand take would you need. My count was.
She to all but I have to get to my senses and I tell my
son my son this is.
What I said well you are not American don't know if you don't have money
that should you take but I always wish for you
every everybody makes
mistakes and that's where you go to confession if you make mistakes.
Misty a job or your college. If you
want it back.
But other people will draw on
the net a tightening.
I
said
that a
few years and move on and makes mistakes.
You can't see.
Our girls
for. When I was young I
always have to make an appointment to talk to me you know years
and I want time.
And same time different.
Ultimate to a Twins. I want on Monday. But if I were you on a date
or what but I need time to get
I did.
I says I was saying in that kind of energy you do you know
you could be a man you're dealing with so I woke up. At the door and I was
a i.o.u like myself you know a story or scene
pool scene poor Wendy who are you sure are no was he was
persecuted Christians killed a Christian. And she's appeared to
him he said. So that's
why persecute
me in the Senate and a poem in a Minister
who he had back and he be a follower. And became a
great apostle. So I related to myself. And
I'm just saying I was a guy.
Knocking off my high horse and he brought me down below and. I go
to go to Rory not to go to myself I
know not to father if you can use
solar energy me I'll never do
it. You know and I want to go
Hold
it. And they come back into we go buy tickets
which he misses five dollars per year. I don't want to be short
but as a final one is trying
to pay back my own no go and say that I mean I know you would.
When I come back Dr and Mrs Howe says she's a baby.
And she's just a comment. Do you want to eat and. Do you have
two kids to move to we pause and he said
no I didn't I just did I couldn't you know. Me was famished I was
sobbing. But my pride always get me away and I said Yes it's too big we were downstairs.
I wanted many kids cookies and Carrie. But in one hundred when
and where my sense is what have you on your show I don't know.
I must or drop that hundred The bigger.
You know you do Fred but I will never know actually
answering ferments and even in my whole family I said I
was always the youngest but I never want to dance anybody and into more money
and I help them all
out by I never asked for anything. My kids and I see
some people my family Irish is
that when you drink is that distilled into how much I put your kids' shoes matter.
So I know it and you know I never take a break and
choose ice and I just you just buy me get you do you just go to fit but don't mind shoes on I
know just like you for your kids kids aged.
But I'm the father I'll do I'll buy
that that I'll never take from anybody. And
just yes just wired in this and.
I'll give it I will take the help a lot of poor people I have
just as she says.
Does people don't have any food. To take to get whatever for thinking.
And you know it was all through my family through just me. Two
hundred two hundred.
But again. When the million people money I So you know
twenty hours. You don't pay you back to what a lot of us sort of move.
And when it when he said as Johnny Thomas said how much we owe you twenty so
you never bother you again
so that's where the money I don't know going to a once in a
year and I'm going to get so I had just time but I was
taking strike. Well thanks for talking with.